organisez l'aménagement urbain tout en
préservant la terre voilà la réflexion
au coeur de la seconde biennale
d'architecturé de paysage d'île de
france cet événement se déroulera du 13
mai au 13 juillet 2022 architectes
paysagistes et urbanistes sont mises à
l'honneur à travers la thématique terre
et ville c'est un moment des changes
c'est un moment doré schisme en
culturelle c'est un moment de
présentation c'est un moment au travers
duquel on repense la ville on repense
urbanisme on repense l'acte de
construire de créer la vie d'essayer de
prendre en compte d' intégrer
l'impératif de l'urgence écologique de
la transition écologique à laquelle nous
sommes confrontés
comment construire une ville plus
durable après l'édition 2019 la cité
royale accueille à nouveau ce
rendez-vous versailles une illustration
de l'esprit de la biennale
d'architecturé de paysage versailles
fait partie des très rares villes mondes
que compte notre pays que c'est une
image connue au delà de nos frontières
c'est un patrimoine architectural qui
est un véritable écrin pour présenter
l'ensemble de ces expositions au
programme de cette seconde édition de la
bap des colloques et des débats et neuf
expositions proposées au public à
travers la ville de versailles
découverte de lauréades architecture de
nouveaux matériaux ou encore parcours
dans le potager du roi un focus sera
aussi fait sur des grands projets
d'urbanisme en ile de france vous allez
avoir deux expositions très grand public
aux médias qui sont l'une sur la
présentation du village olympique plein
jeux olympiques a été pensé par
dominique perrault qu'elle commissaire
de cette explosion à un architecte
français très connu en france l
international et puis une autre
exposition qui lie la présentation du
pavillon
sur les projets des cars du grand paris
lors de la première édition en 2019 plus
de deux cent mille visiteurs ont
participé à la biennale d'architecturé
de paysage